guys it actually happened nicola
nico kovacs has officially signed on
with g2 esports
do you know what that means that means
kenny s and nico
are on the same team and nico doesn't
even have to igl
yeah you heard it here first return of
the headshot machine
now let's just calm down a second and
ask some serious questions like
is this the best move for nico will g2
win the next major and
in all seriousness what's the next for
faze clan
okay guys you know the drill now is the
part of the video where i remind you
that if you haven't already
and it would be egregious subscribe to
the score
esports youtube channel and hey if you
do have a news tip for the don't at me
team
you can reach them at tips at the score
dot com you never know
it might actually become a video anyways
in a year filled with
honestly pretty much just negative cs go
news
g2 esports and nico gave us something to
get excited about this week
and they did it with one of the best
announcement videos i've ever seen
[Music]
[Music]
i mean at this point forget about the
colossus never mind the juggernaut
because it looks like g2 esports
is building a titan you see what i did
there now i think broadly speaking the
move has the potential to do
two things number one unlock nico and
get him to that
number one in the world major winning
spot that we all know he has the
talent to be number two take g2 esports
from a good team with flashes of
brilliance
to one where excellence is the standard
and not just the flavor of the month
i mean don't forget guys that team
baguette was a top three team in the
world at various times this year
and the number one team in the world at
one point in june
and now here we are in october and they
are out of the top 10
for the first time in over nine months
g2 esports
does need something and it looks like
they've decided that nico
is going to be that something and what
he brings to the team is
pretty obvious i mean the chinese import
can save and drop
ops for kenny s his cousin's on the team
which is a plus and
apparently his contract lasts until he
sucks
[ __ ] it's just another esports troll
never mind now let's get serious for a
second here because i do have some
legitimate questions about this move
first and foremost will nico be igling
for g2 esports
because that was speculated as a
weakness in his play when he started
doing that for faze clan
and for the answer to that i turned to
malik g2 esports cs go coach who made
some time for me
for this interview there is always some
doubts because we have like a
professional troll
of twitter in the name of nexa he loves
to mess around on twitter a lot
nico will not in game leads here nexa is
uh i have a good relationship with nexo
about how we work together
and as i said before it will fill a lot
of gaps you will not
most likely be at the same position as
next on the map so it's like just
having another voice some fresh ideas
but it will just be a player
that talks more than others but we will
start
by doing that and we don't plan at all
to have him as an in-game leader i think
he's very happy to
to go back to a more play role we will
make sure that we use him as best as we
can and
that's what we plan to do i also asked
malik how does niko specifically
solve g2 esports problems and help them
get back to that number one spot they
were in
in june in terms of um migrant calling
to help nexa uh in terms of like
experiences about power city sides his
roles like on the big rotations
decision-making to move the team around
to retake areas
and be a bit more active not out of
robotic reaction that we planned and i
really think that having nico will help
us to have more consistency
since he's like bringing like better
communication better experiences better
reads
overall i also asked him in all honesty
what is the team expectation here now
that nico's on board
is it when a major or die trying i think
it's very easy to answer that
since i arrived the goal is just to get
on top um
i don't know if it's winning one
specific title or if it's
yeah winning a major basically is one
one thing we can say we
let's not let's not lie here just
getting better
moving forward every time we have an
opportunity we within the same team
making the team better uh every day we
have seen that we can compete on a
really high level
with the lineup we had already uh having
nico there
will just like put us in an even more
strong position
now from the original announcement it
seemed like g2 was going for
an astralis style six-man roster but
malik told me that's actually not the
case he says we can expect a decision on
a final five-man roster
by the end of the year this is not a
six-man roster we will stay six
till uh winter break i really love all
of
my players the five of them before nico
joins we will make a spot to nico i
think it's a
great thing to do and we will move
forward with that uh
what we will do is testing on the field
we will try out different combinations
because we really would like
to see the best synergy on the field
what is working best for our system
to have the best results possible now
look in case any of you guys forgot nico
really is a generational talent when it
comes to counter-strike
he's an aimer of nearly unparalleled
skill and when he first
burst into the public consciousness back
in 2015-ish on mousesports he produced
some highlights
that are so iconic we still use them in
some cs go videos today
from them very very quickly by
scientists oh my god niko
oh my lungs i don't believe it shocks
then
has just to find one more the molly
isn't going to touch him
and what on earth has just happened is
deagle is on fire and shocked is going
to walk into it as well nico
is on fire and after that he signed on
with the faze clan super team
playing alongside legends like guardian
olofmeister
kerrigan and reign he helped them get to
a major grand final
speed run iem new york and win about a
half a dozen other
major tournaments but once the shine
wore off the faze clan super team
once kerrigan left and that fifth spot
became a little less stable
once nico started taking the dedicated
igl role
things did trend downward for him in
2019
he had his lowest hltv rating since 2016
and he was left out of the top 10
players in the world now mind you he was
number 11
but if you're niko the nikko that's not
really good enough
that's not good enough and so here we
are looking at a faze clan whose time
seems to have passed at least when it
comes to nico
and it's not like he isn't a great
addition to that roster or
it's not a great organization for him to
be a part of
it's just that you can't help but feel
that the
partnership between faze clan and nico
has run its course it's been well over
three years since he signed with faze
clan and
nico hasn't won a major yet and again if
you're that caliber of player
that's just not good enough i mean let's
just be honest here guys
faze clan should have won the boston
major they didn't
and i'm not gonna make this video about
what faze clan should or shouldn't have
done
but the point is if nico couldn't get it
done
in three and a half years with faze was
he realistically ever going to
i think it was pretty clearly time for a
change and hey
i don't know if g2 is the answer for
nico or nico is the answer for g2
but i can't wait to find out which
brings us to the other side of this
whole equation
which is faze clan a team who honestly
still have
plenty of firepower even without nico
especially
with the recent signing of kyarbi they
will have to figure out who's taking the
igl reigns but they're still
a deadly squad of four absolute killers
unfortunately for them though nico
wasn't the only loss to faze clan this
week
the same day he announced his transfer
to g2 esports their coach yanko ponovich
announced that he was leaving the team
and taking a break from coaching
until 2021 so in one single day
faze clan lost two crucial layers of
leadership
their igl and their coach and that to me
is the more worrying sign for faze clan
especially since yanko
said in his parting statement quote for
a while now the team has been struggling
with some reoccurring
issues in and out of the game which i've
done my best to try and amend but
unfortunately without much
success end quote which suggests that
the problems in phase clan might not be
an easy fix
but hey where there's a wallet there's a
way and phase clan have plenty of cash
and plenty of clout to fill those rules
with top tier talent
g2's next game will be on monday against
furia
as part of the blast fall series and
it'll be the first time that we see nico
and g2 colors
who knows maybe he'll pop off maybe
he'll have a bad game
it doesn't really matter what matters is
that it represents a second chance for
one of cs
go's true great players a second chance
at
fulfilling that destiny and hopefully
winning that major
and can you imagine if he did it with
kenny s
now that is a story of video i'd like to
see
now that niko is no longer with faze
clan you know we have to
maybe you know cool it with the phasing
up maybe we can't
phase up anymore maybe we have to g up
right
i've been thinking about this i've been
giving this some thoughts very important
to have
hand signs for your team and you know i
was
thinking g2
g up like this right see that my thumb
doesn't really
bend in the way i need it to but you
know g2 gamers too man
g up throw them g2s up you know you know
you're at the major a
g2 you know